es la primera visita de un presidente
iraní a Siria desde 2010 ebrahim Racing
llegó con una amplia delegación
económica y política para reforzar Los
lazos entre ambas naciones
con el presidente sirio achara la Sad
firmaron acuerdos en varios sectores
como el petróleo agricultura y comercio
los membranos de entendimiento firmados
y los numerosos proyectos discutidos
harán avanzar grandemente las relaciones
mediante mecanismos para incrementar el
intercambio comercial y las inversiones
entre ambos países además mitigarán el
impacto de las sanciones aprovechando
los cambios en el mapa económico global
y la transición gradual hacia el
equilibrio en el este When Hawking
Esperamos que estos acuerdos se apliquen
especialmente en el ámbito económico y
comercial donde existe una buena
capacidad en ambos países
junto a Rusia irá nacido uno de los
principales apoyos del régimen sirio
desde el inicio de la guerra civil Los
acuerdos son cruciales para Siria cuya
economía tocó fondo en la última década
pero los críticos creen que es un nuevo
intento de Irán de aumentar su
influencia política
[Aplausos]
el hecho de que el régimen iraní y el
régimen de asad siguen estrechando lazos
Debería ser motivo de preocupación no
solo para nuestros aliados y socios y
para los países de la región sino
también para el mundo en general
Bradley
la visita se da en un contexto de
reordenamiento en la región Las Naciones
árabes que antes abogaban por la caída
de asad han comenzado a acercarse a
Damasco Incluso se ha discutido el
regreso de Siria a la liga árabe de la
que fue excluida en 2011 y cuando Irán
parece haber limado asperezas con su
archirrival Arabia Saudita gracias a la
mediación china